hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're moving
over a pretty cool opening it's the
colorado game but the rise from the name
is ours to finish if you're not too
familiar with that that is pawn to e4 a
knight c6 and then a knight to f3 now
more common for white to play pawn to d4
but Knight to f3 is probably second to
that now the Colorado game it is pawn to
f5 any time I talk about any sort of
opening or specifically a game but I
like to talk about the soundness of this
this is a pretty good gambit all things
considered I like to play this myself I
wouldn't necessarily take this into a
tournament if I was really prepping
playing a lot of opponents especially
with you know maybe two hours on a match
or so we have tons of time to think this
is more of kind of a surprise tactic if
you're playing maybe fifteen minute
thirty minute game against an opponent's
this is going to be pretty good for that
especially if you're giving it to maybe
a blitz or bullet type of chess game
it's definitely good for that can put
your opponent in a lot of tough
situations but anytime you are playing a
gambit in particular playing even for
whites or for black playing a pawn on
the F file it is going to be somewhat
tricky and it's definitely not as sound
as some of the other openings out there
so don't take this to your local
tournament say that Kevin said this is
the all-time greatest
opening but it is extremely fun and you
get to play it quite a bit this is
fairly common for white to play Pawnee
for a knight to f3 so check it out let
me know what you guys think we're first
going to start look at some of the lines
where white does not take the pawn here
and some of them start with pawn to e5
just pushing forward so as control of
the start of the board his knight on f3
is still protecting this then we're
going to play pawn to d6 now there's a
few options that white has here he could
take with this pawn that's fairly common
also fairly common to just play bishop
here to b5 now once we see this we're
going to take with our pawn here and
then usually Knight takes here on e5 and
then Queen down here to d5 this is
attacking both of these pieces and y can
kind of take with either piece if he
wants to if he takes with his nights
here on c6 then we have kind of two
options we can take with our pawn
here or we could just go absolutely
crazy and we're going to say Queen takes
here on g-tube just a heads up in this
video there's going to be lots of
variations that we're going to look at
some of which may be just a little more
sound I'm going to be going over the
crazier options if you're going to play
a game specifically the the Colorado
game but you're looking for some crazy
and that's exactly what kind of Queen
here to g2 is it's so very very solid
this night still has to get out of the
way all of a sudden you're attacking the
rook here on h1 so this is still very
good but just kind of keep that in mind
as we're going over some of these
variations now you know even from here
we can see Knight takes on a 7 we could
see c6
attacking the bishop all of a sudden
rook to F once and that's being attacked
the route can now take here on a7 the
bishops going to have to move back here
black is actually winning in this
position so that's definitely going to
be very good if we come back and say
okay what if the knight doesn't take
their on a7 could try to try something
with Queen to h5 but then pawn g6 then
we can see Knight back here a5 that's
check but then pawn to c6
all of a sudden black is just in a
really good spot attacking the Queen
attacking the bishop attacking the rook
is just kind of all over the place why
it's not going to be able to castle any
side very safely at all all in all this
is going to be very very good enough we
come back even in this spot and say you
know Queen to g2 and then maybe Knight
to e5 discovered attack on the King and
so we kind of have to deal with this
Knights or kind of that this Bishop
attacking okay from here this is
completely fine we play pawn here to c6
and then maybe the bishop takes the pawn
takes this is still going to be good the
Queen is attacking both the rook Tekkit
or defending the square here on a c6 so
all in all this is going to be very very
good for black then we come back a few
moves and say even in this particular
spot maybe the Knights not going to take
but maybe the Queen automatically comes
into the red zone here Queen to h5 check
the thing gets pretty crazy so we get
see pawn to g6 we can see the night
taking here on g6 and this is a common
theme you'll see throughout a lot of
these variations is then I can always
come taking on g6 because if the pawn
takes all of a sudden the rook is now
going to fall here on h8 there's not a
lot of protection from this King so a
lot of times that is pretty scary but we
are kind of going to go for the crazy in
most of these situations so after the
pawn takes here on g6 which is what I
would recommend and the Queen takes here
on h8 that's fine Queen comes down here
to g2 rook f1 and then Knight f6 and
this does get pretty crazy but as you
can see that that's going to be ok white
does not have good protection for his
King it's going to be very difficult for
him to get all of his pieces on the
Queen side of Albin to the game his
queen although it is very aggressive it
doesn't have any other pieces actually
helping it out in the attack so all in
all this is going to be a good attack
for black nav we come back we kind of
looked at what happens if the knight
takes we also kind of looked at what
happens if the Queen gets involved you
can also take with the bishop so bishop
here on c6 we see pawn taking on c6 the
Knights not going to take now it's
probably better if the knight comes back
here to f3 this is more sound but
sometimes players like to be more
aggressive and they could see you know
night here on e5 I could play Queen here
to h5 this looks pretty good right here
but after Queen to h5 now pawn to g6 it
gets a little crazy because if we see
Knight to g6 now Knight to f6 and this
is where it gets pretty chaotic this is
a much different situation than early if
you kind of want to go back into it now
White's in a really really bad spot
black is going to win this game more
than likely hopefully they've watched
this video and i know how to kind of
approach this but there's a lot of ways
that black in just dominate and all
depends on kind of where white goes from
here what we can already see if the
Queen does not move the Queen is going
to fall here on h5 so we can see first
Queen here to g5 the pawn is going to
take here on g6 if the Queen takes
hey sure that's completely fine check
King here to d8 and that's that's fine
it's
here oh all of a sudden black is up that
minor piece this one queen is involved
but he can't really do anything all the
other pieces are protected for black and
yes it is a little bit chaotic but if
you look from white he has no other
pieces really involved into the action
black is completely dominating the
center of the board all of his pieces
can really dominate these rooks can get
you know semi open file here already
send me open file here on the H file so
all in all this is going to be extremely
extremely good in game for black now if
we come back and say it was instead of
Queen to a g5 what about Queen to h4
okay well now we could just take here on
g2 this threatens both the rook here on
h1 also the night here on g6 now there's
a few options y could say yeah I'm just
going to go ahead and take here on h8
okay perfect we're going to go and take
on h1 then King to e2 and then we have a
few options we could probably play the
safer route of just Bishop to a6 d3 kind
of stopping that Queen over here to c1
just gobbling up at zero black is just
an absolute dominating position right
here just so many active pieces and just
doesn't have anything that he can really
attack his opponent or if you wanted to
you could try to get a little bit more
creative after king - e - you could play
pawn to f4 just kind of stopping a lot
of what your opponent's trying to do but
really opens up the door for the bishop
to come here to g4 this Bishop is being
defended by the knight on f6 so this is
really good this Queen's still attacking
the bishop so if maybe white wanted to
play Knight here to c3 to kind of open
up for the rook to kind of defend this
bishop here on c1 then black has the
very powerful Bishop to g4 White has the
option you can either lose this Queen
and just play Queen six here on g4 or it
can avoid that but then it's going to be
a checkmate from here so the variation
could continue from here we could see
King to d3 Queen to f1 King up here to
d4 most of these are forced moves castle
on the Queen side check King up here too
five Queen here to e1 this is a pretty
intense mate but it is it is good if you
ever actually get to do it in a game
Quinn up here to e to capture and that
night was here was just a just to draw
the game out as much as possible could
have lost earlier if wanted to now rook
down here to d4 King g3 and then Queen
here to f3 so all now
checkmate but that's only if you just
want to get really really tricky and
play that pawn to f4 I think it's just
easier just to play Bishop here to a6 so
that's going to be completely fine of it
is if your opponent takes here on h8 but
if you just plays rook to f1 that's
going to be completely fine as well
because you just come up here to g6
take that material you're up that minor
piece your opponent does not have a
protected King all in all this is going
to be very very good so that's what
happens if the Queen comes near to h4 if
it comes back here to h3
okay well this is a pretty easy game
here pawn takes on a g6 if your opponent
now wants to take on h8 that's fine
Queen takes on g2 rook here to F 1 and
then Knight down here to g4 getting
ready to get more involved into the
attack Knight takes here on g2 or h2 if
you wants to more attacks over here and
the center of the board can always get
bishop involved to a6 if he wants to so
all in all going to be a very very good
game from black now if we come back a
little bit further another option that
he has is Queens who e 2 okay that's
another option that he has from now
we're going to play Queen takes on g2
rook over here F 1 and then just pawn
takes here on g6 so some of the
variations that you could see if your
opponent tried to tray that play that
tricky Queen over here to h5 the next
variations we're going to look at
involve the pawn taking here on d6 now
I've seen a couple people say that you
should take over the pawn here from east
7 other people said you could take from
your pawn here from c7 I think both of
those are bad just from exactly what
you're trying to do you try to be super
super aggressive I don't think those
accomplish really what
trying to do you're trying to be super
aggressive so I recommend pawn to e5
just blast in the center of the board
and sometimes your opponent will just
tried to gobble up more and more
material on board that's fine it doesn't
matter to me
how much material I give up on board I'm
just trying to have the most aggressive
attack possible when I play the Colorado
gambit so if they play this pawn takes
on c7 hey fantastic Queen here to c7 I
control the center of the board which
you usually don't get to say when your
opponent plays pawn to e4 you have a
very active board your LightSquared
bishop can get involved into the game
your dark square bishop be involved into
the game your Knights already
controlling the SIRT of the board with
these two pawns all this is going to be
pretty good now your opponent from here
has a few options you may see pawn to d4
trying to break up the center ok pawn to
e4 and this is something you'll kind of
see anytime you have a pawn here on f5
and pawn to e4 you're kind of almost
looking to push this pawn here to e4 now
it gets kind of tricky because this
somewhat looks like an outpost but if we
see Knight to e5 we could you see the
exchange on board but after the Queen
takes on e5 this is going to just be
much better for black both sides are
equal in material but black is just
dominating the center of the board white
hasn't moved any of his pieces on the
board so that's not going to be good for
white at all now we could see a knight
over here to g5 than just Knight to f6
that's going to be completely fine on
board another thing you could see is
Knight to c3 okay that's fine we're just
still going to push forward with pawn to
e4 and same logic Knight here to g5 9 f6
and this is going to be completely fine
what if instead we see Bishop here to c4
you probably guessed it pawn here to e4
that's going to be fun and then if we
see something okay pawn to e4 he's kind
of analyzed this in plays pawn to d3
okay we'll try something else Bishop
here to c5 getting more pieces involved
into the game just putting more pressure
on our opponents also our opponent try
to be pretty aggressive with pawn to e4
start in the game and all of a sudden
black is just dominating the center of
the board so although this is going to
be a fairly fairly good game for black
now we'll go ahead and take a look at
some of the other options as far as
moving the pawn up here to e5 some of
them in
Blue Knight to c3 okay we're just going
to go ahead and take this material here
on e4 that's fine now the knight could
take we're going to play pawn down here
to d5 trying to control this urn the
board open up the door for some of our
bishops to get involved into the game
depending on where opponents go Knight
to c3 is probably bad just moving it
back that that seems kind of odd we'll
just push forward with pawn to d4 if you
play is kind of the more logical Knight
over here to g3 okay that's fine just
push forward with pawn to e5 controlling
the sear of the board open up or both of
our bishops to get involved into the
game maybe now Bishop to b5 now Bishop
over here to g4 hey this is going to
play pretty well for black very very
aggressive knowing that there's a
semi-open file for you no black over
here so you may want to look to castle
on the Kings side have this rook control
the semi open F file that's definitely
an option on board now if you see
anything else in the game don't try to
overthink and if your opponent plays
Bishop here to c4 just because he's a
know what you're up to and he really
likes to get his Bishop here to c4 to
try to attack this square here on f7
that's right now not defended at all
don't overthink it just take your on e4
put your opponent in a lot of pressure
right here this is going to be
completely fine you can also see some
pretty boring ways that Y could finish
so pawn to d3
it's very passive there's no way with
this kind of strong defense to do
anything too crazy
from this position I usually just try to
be as aggressive as possible so pawn to
e5 you know now if you were to take our
pawn that's fine pawn to d5 opening up
the door for our LightSquared Bishop to
take this material back control the
center of the board that's fine but
all-in-all white could just not take
this even play bishop here to e2 Castle
on the Kings side they could just decide
I don't know what is going on so I'm
just going to hunker down here and try
not to make any mistakes you definitely
could see that the lacerations we're
going to go over is what happens if the
pawn takes the game adhere on f5 now
generally if there's a gambit you almost
kind of want your opponent to take that
gambit in the Colorado game it I
actually don't want my opponent to take
the game but I feel like they're in a
stronger position when
take that pawn there on a5 than when
they're not but all in all you still
need to be aware of what happens if your
opponent does take that wa now we're
going to start with pawn to d5 so that's
kind of the easy point and then it comes
down to what our opponent does now
probably the strongest move for white as
if he plays Bishop here to b5 and this
is one of those where if I walked into a
tournament and the game started like
this I would kind of second-guess myself
as far as why actually you know played
the Colorado gambit my opponent is
playing perfectly here it kind of puts
me in a tough spot now you're not at a
loss by any means you still have a good
game that you could play from here but
it's definitely not as good as some of
the other variations we've looked at in
this video so far from here you're just
going to continue to take so Bishop here
on f5 taking that material then we see
Knight to e5 so we've kind of seen this
before but now kind of puts us in a bind
the bishop now needs to come back here
to d7 because you're just in a tough
spot now if the bishop takes we see
Bishop take that's fine we could see the
knight take and then the pawn recapture
that's fine or if we just see castle on
the King side Knight to f6 we just
develop like a normal game right here
this is going to be completely fine now
if instead of the bishop taking we could
now see the Queen come into the game so
Queen to h5 pawn to g6 Knight takes
we're just going to now see Knight to f6
kind as we've seen before now if the
Queen has not come to h4 in this
particular spot because it's a little
bit different the Queen can't come here
to h3 because the bishops now here the
light-square bishop so he almost has to
come to age 4 or it's going to be kind
of a lost game and we're going to
continue with our game plan we've done
before we're going to go ahead and take
here and then if you decides to go ahead
and take hey that's that's completely
fine we're just now going to play Knight
to b4 and this is threatening the fork
here on the c2 so the bishop comes back
to protect that we're just going to go
ahead and take that and then Bishop here
to f5 attacking this pawn now if you
look at this and say hey this is just
complete chaos
I usually like a more you know
structured game Colorado game it's
probably not for you and any time my
opponent kind of starts out with taking
that pawn and then playing that the
bishop up here to b5 if I can get to
this chaos position which I really like
I feel
is almost kind of a win for me because
that's kind of where I want to be so we
come back instead of that Knight to e5
early on just from right here so you all
kind of see this you can also play a
little bit more more normal could play
castle on the kingside this is fine pawn
to e6 just opening up the door for the
dark square bishop begin involved I
usually like to get my lights for a
bishop out before I play this pawn to e6
so that it doesn't block it off that's
just in general terms I like to do that
as well so this is going to be fine the
Queen King evolved into the game Oh
black still controls the center of the
board a little bit with this pawns here
so this is going to be a good game for
black now then the move you may see from
white is pawn to d4 we're going to
continue with the same game plan bishop
takes here on f4 f5 excuse me get that
material back now if we see bishop here
to b5 it's a little bit different before
we don't have to panic quite as much
even if the knight comes up here to e5
that's going to be completely fine
because white kind of lost to move here
with pawn to d4 now probably a very good
position for white just holistically but
he did lose a little bit so now we can
play pawn to e6 and not worry now Knight
comes to e5 we don't have to panic as
much we don't have to you know worry
about any shenanigans instead we can
play Bishop here to e6 and this is this
is not bad at all now if we see Knight
here to c6 we could just see Queen here
to d7 we're not as big of a threat at
all
now we're kind of threatening the pawn
taking here just keep in mind if you do
see any craziness maybe Knight takes
here on a7 go ahead and take our play
pawn to c6 just to make sure now he's
almost kind of forced to kind of come
back here take with this Knights we are
attacking both the bishop and the
Knights here on a 7 so if you do see
that do just keep that in mind
instead of Bishop even coming up here if
we come back here and set the Bishop
coming up here to b5 none of it we could
see is Knight to c3 from here same kind
of game playing pawn to e6 and then just
kind of call it a day now another thing
we could see is instead of playing pawn
appear
Toodee for our pony could try to hold on
to this pawn here on f5 you don't see it
too often but there's two ways that you
could see that kind of approach the
first one is Bishop here to d3 this does
block off his pawn here on d2 which I
don't really like myself I think this is
a poor move from white but you could see
it from here we're going to just start
to attack more this pawn here on f5 by
playing Knight to h6 now so his opponent
try something crazy
maybe Knight to h4 then we're going to
play pawn to e5 opens up the door for
our LightSquared Bishop to attack he's
really not going to take here on passant
because then his Knights just going to
fall so that's going to be a mistake
here if he tries to get too crazy
maybe Queen here at h5 because some
players any time this square here on f7
is not occupy they're always looking for
the queen and come over here to h5 this
is going to be fine but you need to you
do need to bring your knight back here
to f7 and then maybe you know the bishop
comes over here to b5 pawn here to g6
and then after they exchange on board
then you essentially are going to have
the Queen come back here so maybe Queen
comes back here to g4
now the pawn takes and the knight can't
take here on fi this is a really good
spot for black if you kind of look at
yes he's not going to be able to castle
that's going to be completely okay but
he completely controls the center of the
board now if you kind of look at the
knight and the Queen there's two pieces
both attacking the square here on f5 but
Knight to f5 that would lose Queen to f6
this is pretty much just all bad for
white the knight can't move it's kind of
pinned down the Queen would lose but
then all of a sudden the bishops going
to be taking here on f5 so that's
definitely going to be bad if instead
you know sometimes white will say okay
I'm just going to concede that pawn
there on f5 which they probably should
do so maybe the King castles over here
that's going to be fine now we can just
go ahead and take our bishop as we are
take the pawn here with our bishop as we
thought and then if you want to take our
bishop that's fine we'll just recapture
with our knight now the other option
that you may see also very uncommon is
for the pawn to come up here to g4 to
hold on
to it there's a few ways to kind of
attack this but I usually play pawn to
h5 just because I think the player
that's going to be playing pawn to g4 is
probably not a good player and they're
probably the same type of player that's
going to just continue trying to control
it with pawn to h3 this is kind of in
that Blitzer bullet game or maybe you're
just playing a subpar player that makes
a lot of mistakes I do want to know how
to really just capitalize on those
playing something like pawn here to h5
you're already the aggressive player
that they play this okay pawn to g4
they can't recapture because you can
just come down and take their rook here
on h1 but you're also threatening this
night here on f3 the knight doesn't have
a lot of good moves but it comes up here
to g5 then all of a sudden the bishop
takes out f5 is we kind of wanted it to
we're controlling the sword of the board
this Knights kind of in no-man's land
later on we could look to play pawn to
e5 just completely controlling the
center of the board so all in all this
is going to be pretty good game for
black so this is the Colorado gambit you
have a lot of opportunities to play this
so check it out let me know what you
guys think try to make a pretty in-depth
video we couldn't go over all the
possible lines in this but hopefully
this gave you a good idea of some of the
main concepts that you need to think
about when your opponent's playing in
different places if you have other ideas
for openings or variations of other open
things that you'd like me to take a look
at do a video on please leave a comment
or you can also email me that's probably
even the best way it's the chess website
at gmail.com so make sure you send that
feedback to me but thanks everyone for
watching hopefully you guys enjoyed and
let me know how you do with the Colorado
gambit